nous avons fait leur connaissance dans
le journal d'hier isabelle elisson de
tourangelle partis prêter main forte aux
familles ukrainienne depuis lundi nous
suivons leur périple près de la
frontière avec la hongrie aujourd'hui
leur voiture a servi de taxi à des
familles qui souhaitaient fuir leur pays
le jour 2 de leur expédition c'est avec
michael tecsys
et tan tan
et les yeux pétillant et le sourire qui
illumine à nouveau le visage de ces
ukrainiens trois femmes six adolescents
qui ont laissé derrière eux leur mari et
père dans kiev a siégé pour se mettre en
sécurité
ab réole isabelle et sa fille nelly les
deux tourangelle ont accompagné les
familles formalités d usage pour trouver
un hébergement organisation du voyage
vers la touraine ou des amis les
attendent
le voyage se fera en avion puis en train
mais avant il faut passer la frontière
hongroise départ très tôt ce matin
très tôt
quand c'est à une autre journée phare de
la journée il ya trop demande
récente est en train de prendre un petit
café en sont à la croix ma thèse et puis
la main c'est la frontière on voit qu'on
a fait le bon choix de venir si tôt
parce qu'il ya juste une voiture là bas
qu'attend
on a déposé à la frontière alexina et
toute sa famille ni avec les adieux
était un peu déchirant alexis n'a pleuré
quand on s'est dit au revoir je pense
que l a compris qu'elle eut quitté son
pays pour peut-être beaucoup plus que un
mois peut-être même des années nous
sommes un peu pleuré mais c'est vrai que
moi je me suis rendu compte déjà hier en
les accueillant qu'ils étaient partis en
laissant tout derrière eux ils ont pris
un sac à dos chacun c'est incroyable et
puis hier soir quand on discutait avec
eux ils nous ont montré des photos de ce
qui faisait de la danse classique de la
gymnastique de la danse de salon en
concours et tout d'un coup je me suis
dit mais ça aurait pu être mes filles
quoi c'est
très émouvant ça devient concret
isabelle et zélie reste autant d'ukraine
elles ont pris aujourd'hui la route pour
le vivent elles souhaitent se rendre
utile dans cette ville de l'ouest du
pays où des milliers de réfugiés
affluent